Kate Hudson and Nick Jonas is maybe a  date night only et has these pics from  the rumored couples the night out  together  this is them leaving a four-hour long  romantic dinner in LA Wednesday  photons were able to get a few shots of  the pair together but they were quick to  separate two seemingly avoid being  photographed side by side now both Nick  and Kate have played coy about the  rumored romance here's how Kate dodged  ETS question about the 23 year old the  Golden Globes Nick on this carpet you're  asking Matt it's great you're not gonna  tell anything to talk about  just friends really nothing a jolly much  not after he sees you in this dress